thank you oh ah hello hi welcome
everybody to a muscle stimulator Jenga
so you all probably know about Jenga
you know how Jenga works you know how
it's done this is not Jenga this is a
knockoff version because we went
shopping on Black Friday and we were not
able to get the right game for this one
but that doesn't matter because this one
looks even more difficult because it is
actually uneven don't know how they did
it it's goofy some slippery slopes they
made two different size wood blocks so
this is just not what is supposed to be
it's not even close I know right it's
it's rough this sucks
when you try to get a deal I got a bob
you do got a bob so welcome everybody we
are raising money for Save the Children
tonight we've got a long way to go but
we've made incredible progress and thus
far we've raised a hundred and twenty
one thousand dollars for charity
which means that we are going to be well
on our way to our goal of 200 thousand
dollars which is gonna mean that we have
four hundred thousand dollars in total
we hit 120 which means that Tyler is
gonna be bobbing now there's only eight
apples in there left from our pack yeah
sorry I didn't break it with my gigantic
forehead I tried my best man Tyler what
do we what do we still have left
um mark we went over the slow hands
Shawshank Redemption phobia Hat hunters
cat I didn't know we did Shawshank
Redemption um yeah sashenka is off we
haven't done I can't understand you
rubba bub-bub collar shock collar yeah I
think that's it yeah yeah cool alright
yeah go for it
what is he gonna get folks
what's he bobbing for he's almost got
one oh he's getting one still haven't
mastered the art of the Bob he's got
really gonna you got this we believe in
you how's the water it's so cool hot hot
refreshing we've heard that is hot
waters hotter than a tub as hot as it
could possibly be it's so hot in the
studio isn't there right Ethan that's
right it's hotter than it's hotter than
the weather men can even say your totter
whoa
still no progress on that probably be
accidental brother so hot yeah the
weather is hot hot hot spicy hot hot
everyone wants to take their clothes off
everyone everyone wants to take their
clothes off in this studio right here
right now it is so darn hot but favorite
thing this is like you did that head
thing that you do when we record which
is I'm gonna try that again but this is
a live stream you can't there's no
editing you haven't gotten it
oh no but it burns my head hurts all
right anyway back to the high fever
studio sickness rampaging throughout the
streets
nobody's hotter than that man over there
sweat dripping from his brow he's so hot
he's dunking his head in a bucket of ice
oh sorry I bothered of ice ah my bad
over there just a slip at the toilet but
that's okay yeah just suck suck give it
the good suck it it's so cold I can't
stick my head in there for long all
right well whatever one that is that
will say will say it's okay guys I take
some pride all right Wow all righty then
so while Tyler's doing that you guys can
look in the description below there's a
link to tilt to five comm slash at
markiplier it's the donation page where
we're raising money for Save the
Children Save the Children is an amazing
organization because they literally save
children all around the world oh I got
it you got it
hey hey they've helped 187 million kids
throughout the world just last year
alone they helped in education health
care and food so value all right and
ease down what did you get must have
been that fever you got 15
you you're so strong from above bub oh
you know what you get we have to give
him a massage my head hurts but okay
yeah oh my head hurts so bad well don't
worry I can give you a good head inside
all the sides gonna be there for a
little bit so Kyla you relax with rest
and relax
we'll get the massage oil underway I'm
gonna put these muscle simulators on nah
come on is fine since I laying down is
good why you didn't do that look this is
the kind of dedication that we have here
because we are so so so dedicated to
this cause and that means that we are
willing to put our very lives on the
line we've got a fever and the only cure
there we go
the only cure is cure is real reaching
that donation goal of 200,000 because we
have an anonymous donator that is
willing to donate up to $200,000 or
match up to $2,000 which is a Rancho
mm Oh $200,000 which would be a grand
total if we hit that goal of $200,000 of
$400,000 donated to save the children
here you take this car boil you I'll
take this water release should we should
we have them lay right up on here on the
massage yes yes please donate to warm my
brain warm is brands here here here how
do you have that muscle stem I got you I
don't I'm gonna do it
I did and stick your head in freezing
cold water it is not really on the scat
paddles pillows palos pillows pillows
pianos pianos villapiano's
Pablo get him Cosmo Picasso more MORE
we're gonna lay you across this whole
thing one more maybe two more very what
friends do
half a dozen ah Tyler lay mute mute my
mic
that's right straddle careful of that
mic that too right next to you you're
good you're good keep going you're good
man no that's a no we're not gonna smack
his ass nah no no nothing face we're a
family friend no John no no no you're
doing the chicken
I found a Katherine here all right
where's my utterly smooth body cream
where are we putting this right all
night on that right on she Oh che che ah
with this shea butter it's not coconut
oil spritz this is body butter no body
cream first side you're gonna smooth
skin you're gonna be oily yeah v be not
on line smooth non greasy body cream
deeply moisturizes your skin making even
dry and cracked skin fear utterly soft
and smooth originally developed for use
on dairy cows I'm a dairy cow and now
used by people of the world no you gotta
you gotta give your cow Chow sauce oh
that feels
I mean you miss I like sour cream what
the hell is half wait what look at this
if I just push it's just like explode
oh my god all right well no not okay
that oh that happened creamy creamy I
hope we have towels to wipe this all ha
no no no no no you're a cow now oily
that's all right that's cold all right
this is coldest the ice bucket no not
here I'll get the leg okay all right
if you're wondering why we're doing this
is because Tyler just put himself
through hell to try to get an Apple to
punish himself I'm so glad it wasn't the
shot-caller one yeah that would have
been bad you literally got the only one
left that was us do you a favor
I feel like I've gotten all of the you
guys yeah you have it's a little biased
methinks that maybe your eyelids don't
work as well as ours hmm
I've been blindfolded more than anybody
else oh really I've had a ball gag in my
mouth so you can't really say anything's
one way all right no I said I've been
blindfolded that's straight up the truth
I died blindfolded multiple times that's
okay you know what you're not wrong this
is the weirdest feeling in the world and
being this done in front of so many
people is awkward no one's watching no
one's watching no one's watching no ow
ow don't don't smack those that hurts
and it's not the smack it's literally
the edge of the table with my knees oh
that's probably not good all right
are you high and give me a nice moo moo
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey or did you put the cake where is it
in my versions of patty cake I think no
I does the does the massager wipe
themselves down no the massager also
called the masseuse no those will stay
wet yeah I don't know what it was okay
When in Rome when it goes oh why thank
you you're welcome
how do hey leo that's a diet
[Music]
silky-smooth you got to do it like a
shoe shine eNOS shoes this is so good
this would be better if these were wax
do you want us to wax them oh we could
Tyler you want to wax I don't hear a no
later later
later alright fine then yeah okay good
this was awkward his head why now that
wasn't deserving rah blah blah blah rub
a bub bub now if that wasn't deserving
of some donations I don't know what was
so if that was in any way entertaining
to you in any way shape or form what I'm
comfortable or uncomfortable and awkward
remember you can cleanse your soul by
donating to Save the Children googling
in the description below go to tilta v
comm slash @ markiplier and find all the
information there give whatever you can
takes paypal so thank you everybody that
has donated already
thank you everybody that's gonna donate
now we are gonna put these muscle
stimulators on our body where's the
ideal location for this um I would say
try and do your biceps this guy biceps
your triceps okay you got it
you got it good buddy you might need
help from another video
I don't think here's another bad boy
meaning off market black-market Jenga
can you only buy this one on the black
market that's the truth
alright anyway bad joke good job man
good job hey we only build each other up
here that's why we gave him a massage
[Laughter]
okay so no idea so so here's how it's
gonna work we're gonna need your help in
this endeavor these maybe muscle
stimulators but they will only go up if
you guys donate if in this entirety we
get $10,000 during the time that we're
gonna do this segment we will go up in
intensity every thousand dollars as
simple as that you want to see us
supper weight every thousand dollars yes
we'll go up one level of intensity
starting at zero starting at one okay
which means that we could take this all
the way up to 11
all right look if you remember from the
shopping mall to ten thousand dollars
okay there yeah yes I was very afraid
for a second really where we stand right
now so if you guys want to see a supper
and I'm gonna just test this out right
here boy to me go buddy Wiggly enjoy
what do you do I've heard it up to eight
I had I wanted to test you wanted to
test you've done this before yeah but I
wanted to just make sure my anchor
points were good food okay what if you
put the places among them atop your
buttocks think you'd get a nice firm
would we will try that later
right after rubble Baba but at the
after-hours edition nope I need to
relocate one of these dudes all right so
here's how it's gonna work
I've already explained that so got a
little bit about Jing Li there yeah I
feeling now all right so who's gonna go
first in Jenga uh three-way walk Paper
Scissors yes cuz that actually works it
does work sure it does sometimes
here we go you ready yes I can okay so I
go first no he goes first
Oh then I go that works yeah that
doesn't rate that you know why we did it
oh I have to put the balls inside
because otherwise they fall on hit the
mic ha ha all right
these are horrible
okay alright first move that's good
getting we're already at 1:24 go up
gentlemen really yep oh yeah 23:02 whoa
what level are we at I was at one why is
that so we got two right yeah mine's not
great that's up another one hang on I
don't think I'll survive if I do that
slug the hell is it suddenly got yeah
that's not good
no we're gonna activate tendons you're
going across a joint you need to keep
them on the same no dammit
oh jeez that's that's not my fault
that's why there's two oh yes this is
interesting okay okay we should be
[Music]
alright oh we still have not been
playing Jenga oh yeah I need to go oh
you have to put it on top Ethan oh
that's right alright what happens if it
falls then you lose punishment okay
ah pretty pretty good pretty good pretty
good pretty good
this is the worst Jenga set I've ever
seen are we playing you have to touch it
then it moves or no I don't know why
does it change mine's fine I mean oh
there are different there are different
settings though right I think there's
like a pulse
yeah because if you press mode
it does weird thing oh oh can't boo oh
there's like a spring watch the take way
even was just oh my god I can't this
thing is just wiggling I can't miss out
any further
[Laughter]
come on if you just like roll your arm
and then just let it well my finger this
thing is not your church anyway spasming
smile randomly
so do we go up okay
what oh okay well Elijah I got you like
right here
Oh yep Elijah you're awesome
like this right now it's so I hope you
like it
I can't oh that's okay whose turn is it
yours in just 100 why did we allow
dialer to do this are we going up do we
have to go up oh good I better hurry
okay come on come on
no no ah okay if you want to see us in
more pain go down in the link in the
description below or if you're on mobile
check Twitter and Facebook for the link
to the till to five page that'll take
you right to the donation page where you
can make a donation and see us suffer
even more
oh no I was already doing this sock
that's God's okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know if I can go up higher on
this arm oh oh it just went jingle mom
yeah I'm pretty tingling all right okay
all right go for it
the key is to keep everything tight my
body's natural yes that means winner oh
okay nothing what the careful whoa whoa
you can't hit the top three levels
generally yeah definitely not talked to
okay all right all right just like this
not not good
oh I don't I don't like this right got
it you got it
oh by the way we've been increasing the
intensity of this every thousand so far
we've are we're on level six
think very carefully one Duncan you know
how hard I thought these days
the answer is extreme Oh
going for it well this is the one I call
Tyler's error you got it oh my god I
believe in you goo goo oh my hand almost
just took the whole thing I don't know
the thumping EDM is like no I'm going
with this mood here but it's all we got
at the moment oh good luck we're
currently at 128 thousand three hundred
and seventy eight dollars raised thank
you so much but please continue to give
continue to share this stream tell
everybody about it we've been going all
day long and we've been raising so much
money this is more money than we've
raised in a shorter amount of time than
we've I've ever seen in my entire tea
doing these charity livestreams so
please keep giving and you'll see us
keep suffering it's twelve eight one two
eight four hundred so another six
hundred and then we go yeah what level
are will that be that will be seven oh
good I wanted to make sure I didn't oh
I'm good you're okay you're okay until
you're not okay oh all right this is
what separates the men from the bar
that's what I've had I can't if I bend
this arm when I'm trying to do it it
just wants to take everything out
fine motor control is a little bit it
doesn't want to move well it will move
with your help remember if you haven't
donated yet please consider making a
demo uh bigger small even a one dollar
donation means that that is double one
dollar is two dollars ten dollars is
twenty fifty is a hundred a thousand
dollar donation is a two thousand dollar
donation any amount that you can give is
going to help so if you haven't done
take the time to do it now thank you
everybody
oh we crossed we're going up another we
gotta go oh oh you need to press yours
down they're starting to peel off no you
guys have real problems
yeah get down get down stay down get up
come on get down with the sound wrong oh
no oh no oh no oh oh oh gosh are you
gonna get it well that top is so
precarious
[Music]
you dick oh alright alright hang on wait
I got just like oh my god my shoulders
off I just can't I can't straighten my
arm it's impossible mine shut off no oh
mine shut off to open up mine's still
going strong guys you oh you need to
turn the mode and turn the timer up the
max it'll go is 60 minutes let's do that
so we got to ease our way back up oh
come on arm please I just go forward arm
oh boy come on seven again oh that's so
weird
I've done it I've done it I've got it
okay
oh my god it hurts
hmmm
excuse me okay you're excused
Oh
[Music]
No Oh keep it on you don't turn it off
well it's it for Tyler should probably
turn it off
in the water no Chuck your head in there
we'll get that later we're gonna play
another game oh crap we're up at 1:30 oh
that's one more level oh my god what is
my yeah dragon was just fire-breathing
in the meantime we are still here
streaming for Save the Children if you
haven't already
oh boy or if you still can please please
please donate our goal is two hundred
thousand dollars we're about to hit 130
thousand nine we did we'd have yeah
we've hit 130 thousand dollars but we
still can get up there to two hundred
thousand dollar range and we have a very
generous anonymous donor that is willing
to match up to two hundred thousand
dollars so we hit that two hundred
thousand dollar goal then we will have
raised $400,000 for Save the Children
and go ahead and in that top corner up
there were like fingers pointing there's
a box that fills every 50 dollars and
every fifty dollars gets a baby
life-saving vaccinations nutritional
supplement and their first visit to the
doctor so that the baby has a better
chance at life and being able to survive
and live wonderfully haha
yeah uh-oh - 9 - migraine since I lost
does that mean I get to go first I'm
yeah I'm on 8 okay I'm gonna do
something crazy that's how I do here
markiplier each kilo I'm going to ten
and the only way you can save us now
every thousand dollars donated we will
go down oh okay so you can rescue us
[Applause]
[Music]
that's okay I can't either
I just can't
I can't move my sorter is just going
like oh good good choice good choice
thanks man
[Music]
don't make me activate my web-shooter
give me a finger oh there we go
we need the same the reason I try to
straighten my arm it wants to bend the
other way I'm staying why I'm doing it
10,000 more go up okay I'm sacrificing
myself do I join I can't do it on my
bicep ah thank you Lisa
you're a hero I've gotta love it on my
shoulder
oh I went up to eleven okay you you uh
yes yes okay it's getting better you
know you get used to it after a while
oh you really do I could stay here for a
while oh my bad boys doing it it's that
bad boys seeing what we're for dope
vertel very dope is doing very Dolph
Scott you see very Tom's got a obsidian
ADIS relief down you said did you say up
up didn't you can get good good good
it's not a turn sir
come on cooperate with me please
we go down yes ah Oh carts going up
further down stop I'm gonna try an
ivory-billed Wow while I'm doing this
[Applause]
why are we doing this because we care
because it's and why are we doing this
because we had the idea to no one's
making us do this
not a single person no single person
isn't for that man behind me what your
fault your fault
that's your you said in the beginning
that you made the punishments okay okay
sure wait Bob now ah you guys should go
ahead and Bob relaxing now that's what I
call a good massage that's a good
workout now we got a bob I'll go first
woo all three of us have to Bob right
yes through a triple bob at the same
time watch out for the iceberg hey guys
we have a lot of funnier markiplier HQ
but just remember we're professional
idiots don't try this at home and even
if it's for a great cause like charity
and even if it does Drive a lot of
donations please it up to the profession
no I mean leave it up to the professions
become a professional first and then do
it we know our limits I wouldn't do this
if I knew it was gonna actually do any
damage so be safe and also remember
we're raising money to save joy so thank
you everybody who has been donating so
far we are now to had almost a hundred
and thirty three thousand dollars that
was an incredible spring
that we just did and it's only 6:10
where we are right now
we've still got 20 more minutes like so
we're gonna do a triple Bob punishment
all at the same time
don't forget your lie of bring it out of
it so I could not it's like a high end
get behind again I wasn't on my feet all
right never again ere we go
all right I'll be here you'll be there
and remember you might want to take the
heck oh no oh you've never had puffy
bowl fibers in your mouth no I have
puppies all 5s in my mouth I feel like
these are all really bad ones wait we
can put this back in now this was
beautiful cuz we took it off for this
challenge now we already did that one
will be duplicate once we meet which
will be soon
all right ready guys okay okay let's
close our eyes up somebody to start
close your eyes Christmas night to push
the nap Authority I think wait I don't
have any apples here
chilly an apple 14 was 14 I can't all
right I gotta I can't understand you
yeah shoots me an apple I got no apples
where the apples is that the devil oh
come on guys you got this Romilly
it's been frozen apples took you forever
is it
that's an iceberg where's an Apple as I
always say mark I need you I can't find
an apple as I always say
an apple a day makes
thank good and when you've got an apple
you'll know oh you're starting your day
off right number do no whoa man no so if
you want to start your day off right
with a crisp fresh Apple bit you bobbed
out of the river this morning oh and
just remember if you donate if you
donate today not only will you win the
lottery tomorrow will all your dreams
come true you'll be accepted into a
multi-million dollar acting contract and
wake up twice as beautiful as you
already are because they're doing huh
we're Hamptons you get slide phobia hat
hey donut through the link in the
description below so I got 14 all right
you got slow hands I got what did I get
I can't understand you
you got obeah hat ah the phobia Hat is a
group one so let me just
we could save that that what's the last
one Bob doubt so wait what did Tyler get
I got slow hands slow hands yeah let's
do it all now we can make it work we can
do all of this now why wait when today
is now and then now is now and we have
what we have now so let's do this all
we're gonna do the phobia hat by the way
so the the uh the one that I have which
is I can't understand you is an offshoot
of a game called speak out basically I
have to hold that thing that makes you
not talk in my mouth the entire time
simply do a ball gag but this time you
can actually see the disgusting things
inside my mouth so when we have that in
order and also Tyler has slow hands slow
hand meaning it though is when I just
don't have these giant Mickey Mouse
hands and we fill them with hair gel
because as we just discovered chair gel
is disgusting
we're gonna play another round of Jenga
but before that we're gonna put on what
I like to call and what I made up which
is the phobia hat so now the phobia hat
is a hat that holds in front of you your
worst fear for me
I'm tryptic I don't like the patterns of
small holes and things trip to phobia
it's very real it's not me I also don't
like mannequins but I have mark saw I
dunno I don't want to show that Oh
yes I really don't like feet I really
don't
oh god I just can't what Cathy goes down
I can't
God what are you tripping Bobo get all a
little bit that flinch but I know I have
to look at it one your hold on I need to
tell my I hate clowns
I hate the it clown I hated all the
clowns I hate clowns clowns freak me the
hell out oh no this person why it was
white there are they're like creeping up
on me from the side peripheral is it's
so creepy
thankfully these up here are too close
that I can't really see them I'm not
gonna be able to eat down here these
first of all what is the horse like a
bee like a phobia of feet I just don't
like pattern the worst thing about the
phobia hat is they're just in your
peripheral vision you know you can you
can not you can forget the third there
for a bit and then but for me what's
that freaking foot I don't like that
foot oh that is so gross oh all that is
odd it just makes my skin crawl but no
lie not a joke not an exaggeration I
can't look at a kid you know with this
just like want to do this okay I feel
cold you see single broken bone thing it
would have been that well it just like
makes me like ah because after they're
there for a bit like I don't like them
well like the no like broke it like the
original one was like bones like going
through this gym I know which would have
been terrible for you okay so this heads
gone so I you know when when I took that
hiatus I came up with a lot of ideas I
get it these ideas resulted in things
like the phobia hat which was just
something I was I remember I was on the
couch amy was there I was like what
should we do for a punishment I hate
this [ __ ] hat I hate this so much I
just
oh oh
did you put two you put too much in
there I gotta try and play Jenga with
those on ah this was the worst while I
keep flicking clop that's what happened
I opened my eyes you know I gotta be
able to fit my hands in there guys
Garber might as well just finish off the
bottle I do it's like under my
fingernails this is the worst ever
this is this isn't it coach Joe Joe Joe
oh I need help you're drooling so much
thank you
let's get these we need that we need
something below me because oh the smell
guys forgot how much I hate that all
right I'll go first go so I got hat mmm
in hands you know mine's not that bad
because I kind of winds with a little
cool because the skin going in this
manner
I got your God down
tow know how this come final weird asked
oh I got a thing
good job with hands hands I saw that one
[Laughter]
Nick I can't I keep wanting to use my
eyes to look at you and then I look
straight at what your dad I know I look
at the clown yeah I get this sir why is
it I got one section of this glove that
doesn't have what did you looking for
this gross feet oh yeah whole doughnut
so you could hear like you're hiring
this isn't are you telling you this
[ __ ] real
it's a I get I'm gonna put these back
here I'm gonna give it on the back your
neck okay how do you spell make sure how
am I still able to do this good [ __ ] gun
it's like soaking through I'm trying to
look at it too yeah oh yeah why
[Music]
one hand one block okay with you guys
just move them closer
[Laughter]
this gets back to me would know what
don't even
nobody rush me
look at that mouth you gotta hear this
go go go go we'd have no time what is
this get on the floor somebody didn't
put that up top color too dull no no
[ __ ] god
I'm sorry okay pull it go quick fast get
that dude you just like palm the whole
tower dude oh dialysis with you
they're all just so firm come on look at
the time what if we didn't know eight
you guys I'm trying to play with giant
full of my you're holding it there you
can't do that yeah you can only touch
the block you're moving you can't touch
you can't hold that
look at those clowns mom's got a soggy
face he's gone he cheated Oh God I was
at such a disadvantage she waiting for
me
all right so that's it for Django with
muscle stimulators in the phobia
apparently oh god there's the worst
thing I've ever seen oh you want to see
I am doing the outro uh whatever sign up
Oh doctor how's the delivery messy all
right so thank you guys so much for
doing this but we got more in store for
you two more challenges on the way we
are currently at 135 thousand six
hundred fifty to five dollars we have to
raise $65,000 in the next two challenges
that we're gonna be doing so please join
us raise money tell people about the
tilt to fight page even when we're
offline for the next 30 minutes we'll be
right back with more stuff in just 30
minutes
thank you so much for joining us and
make this happen you guys are amazing
and we are so close we're not gonna give
up now so let's keep pushing till the
end thanks so much we'll see you in 30
minutes okay okay
yeah